THE PAST 48 HOURS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
I READ THROUGH THE ROUGH
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL BETWEEN
TRUMP AND THE NEW UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT.
A FEW THINGS STRUCK ME.
NUMBER ONE, THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
PERSON IN WASHINGTON WITH ANY
EXPERIENCE IN GOVERNMENT, NOT
ONE, WHO REALLY BELIEVES THE
PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO USE THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT TO RING THE
2020 ELECTION.
I DON'T SEE HOW ANYONE IN HIS OR
HER RIGHT MIND COULD
LEGITIMATELY SAY THERE IS AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE IN THIS
TRANSCRIPT.
IN THE CONVERSATION, TRUMP
CONGRATULATED VOLODYMYR ZELENSKY
ON HIS PARLIAMENTARY WIN AND
SAID THE U.S. WOULD CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE BUT HE WAS
FRUSTRATED THAT THE E.U. ISN'T
DOING MORE.
ZELENSKY AGREED SAYING THE
EUROPEAN UNION SHOULD BE OUR
BIGGEST PARTNER.
TECHNICALLY THE UNITED STATES IS
A MUCH BIGGER PARTNER.
WE ARE READY TO CONTINUE TO
COOPERATE FOR THE NEXT STEP
SPECIFICALLY.
ALMOST READY TO BUY MORE
JAVELINS FROM THE UNITED STATES
FOR DEFENSE PURPOSES.
THEN THE PRESIDENT RESPONDS "I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO US A FAVOR
THOUGH BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY HAS
BEEN THROUGH A LOT AND UKRAINE
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT IT.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS WHOLE
SITUATION WITH UKRAINE.
THEY SAY CROWD STRIKE, THE
SERVER, THEY SAY UKRAINE HAS IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CALL YOU OR
YOUR PEOPLE AND I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU DO IT IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE."
ZELENSKY INTERJECTED THAT
INSISTENT HAD MET WITH GIULIANI
AND THAT THE INVESTIGATION WAS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR HIM AS WELL.
ADDING "I GUARANTEE THAT ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS WILL BE DONE
OPENLY AND CANDIDLY.
THAT I CAN ASSURE YOU."
OKAY, HANDLING INVESTIGATIONS
OPENLY AND CAN -- CANDIDLY.
SOUNDS LIKE AN EVIL PLOT.
HOW NEFARIOUS OF THEM.
THERE IS NO QUID PRO QUO AND THE
PRESIDENT NEVER HINTED UKRAINIAN
AID WOULD BE WITHHELD IF A
FURTHER INVESTIGATION WASN'T
DONE.
AT THIS POINT I THINK IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS OVERPLAYED THEIR HAND
BIG TIME.
THEY BASED THEIR IMPEACHMENT
MOVE ON A WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO
DIDN'T EVEN HEAR THE
CONVERSATION AND WHO GROSSLY
EXAGGERATED WHAT HAPPENED IN IT.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO POINT NUMBER
TWO.
THE PRESIDENT NOT ONLY DID
NOTHING WRONG, HE WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND HIS DUTY TO HIS OFFICE,
HOPING TO DISCOVER WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE LEAD UP TO THE 2016
ELECTION SO IT NEVER HAPPENS TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT AGAIN.
AS WE KNOW, THE BIDEN STORY IS
ABOUT FAR MORE THAN JUST HUNTER
BIDEN MAKING BIG MONEY IN
UKRAINE WHILE DADDY WAS SETTING
UKRAINE POLICY.
>> I FULLY SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY
ON THE SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER
INFORMATION BUT ALSO INSIST ON
TRANSPARENCY FROM JOE BIDEN AND
HIS SON, HUNTER, AND THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN QUICKLY AND EASILY TAKEN
OUT OF UKRAINE AND CHINA.
>> Laura: IF FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS WERE APPROACHED TO
ASSIST IN DIGGING UP DIRT ON
TRUMP IN THE LEAD UP TO 2016,
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
AND TRUMP IS RIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
ANY ELECTION TAMPERING.
I THOUGHT DEMOCRATS WANTED TO
STOP ELECTION MEDDLING BY
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
WHICH TAKES US TO POINT NUMBER
THREE.
DEMOCRATS DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT PREVENTING GOVERNMENT
CORRUPTION.
ANY DEMOCRAT CLAIMING TO BE
INTERESTED IN CORRUPTION SHOULD
BE OUTRAGED BY THE FACT THAT
BIDEN HIMSELF BRAVED ON CAMERA
ABOUT DANGLING A FOREIGN AID
CARROT TO GET A PROSECUTOR
FIRED.
WHEN THAT PROSECUTOR WAS
INVOLVED IN INVESTIGATING THE
COMPANY PAYING HIS SON BOATLOADS
OF CASH.
NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT WILL EVEN
CONCEDE THAT BIDEN'S ACTIONS
THAT THE VERY LEAST WERE AN
OBVIOUS CONFLICT OF INTEREST?
IT'S EXTREMELY TELLING.
>> LEAVING IN SIX HOURS AND IF
THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRED,
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
SON OF A [BLEEP].
HE GOT FIRED.
>> Laura: NUMBER FOUR.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED TO
PRESSURE UKRAINE TO HURT BIDEN
WITH THE INTENT ON IMPROVING HIS
OWN REELECTION CHANCES, THERE
WERE A HUNDRED BETTER WAYS TO DO
IT.
BY THE WAY, WAYS THAT WOULDN'T
INVOLVE SPEAKING TO THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ON THE PHONE
WHEN HE KNOWS THAT THE CALL IS
MONITORED AND MEMORIALIZED BY
INTELLIGENT STAFFERS.
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS INSIST TRUMP
WAS PRESSURING UKRAINE TO INVEST
BIDEN -- INVESTIGATE BIDEN, WHAT
DOES THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
HIMSELF SAY?
>> I THINK GOOD PHONE CALL.
IT WAS NORMAL.
WE SPOKE ABOUT MANY THINGS.
I THINK AND YOU READ COVER THAT
NOBODY PUSHED ME.
>> Laura: NOBODY PUSHED HIM.
SO THE PRINCIPAL HIMSELF ADAMANT
NO PRESSURE FROM TRUMP.
THE CALL WAS NORMAL.
NOTHING OUT OF THE ORDINARY.
SO ARE THE IMPEACHMENT DAMS
SAYING THAT ZELENSKY HERE ON CAM
SAYING THAT ZELENSKY HERE ON CAR
SAYING THAT ZELENSKY HERE ON CAA
IS LYING?
SO IT'S A TRUMP UKRAINIAN
CONSPIRACY IN PLAIN SIGHT?
DOES THIS ALL THIS KIND OF SOUND
FAMILIAR TO ANY OF YOU?
PHONY COLLUSION CLAIMS IN 2017,
PHONY PRESSURE CLAIMS NOW.
NUMBER FIVE.
THERE ARE NO MODERATES LEFT IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS POINT IS BEYOND DEBATE.
DURING THE MIDTERMS, SWING
DISTRICT DEMOCRATS CLAIMED THEY
WERE ANXIOUS TO WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW THEY ARE THE TIPS OF THE
IMPEACHMENT SPHERE.
>> THE QUID PRO QUO ELEMENT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE THERE FOR
THIS TO BE A CRIME.
>> THIS WAS A LINE THAT WAS
CROSSED FOR THE NATIONAL
SECURITY DEMS AND SOMETHING THAT
WE THOUGHT THE CAUCUS NEEDED TO
MOVE ON.
>> IT MAY BE A CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FACTS AND YOU LOOK AT THE
SPECIFIC INSTANCE, I THINK IT'S
A TOTAL GAME CHANGER.
>> Laura: IT'S A GAME CHANGER
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE ALL ILHAN OMAR NOW.
WHEN THEY ARE UP FOR REELECTION
AND THEY INSIST, THEY INSIST
THEY ARE MODERATES WHO JUST WANT
GOVERNMENT TO WORK AGAIN.
DON'T BELIEVE THEM.
THEY MUST BE VOTED OUT OF OFFICE
FOR VIOLATING THEIR PLEDGE TO BE
MORE BIPARTISAN.
NUMBER SIX, DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP
HAS TOTALLY GIVEN UP ON
GOVERNING.
TIME AND AGAIN, TRUMP HAS BEATEN
THEM AT THEIR OWN GAME.
WE'VE SEEN IT.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK IT'S MADE
THEM -- THEY ARE LOSING IT.
DAY AFTER DAY, THEY ARE TOTALLY
DELUSIONAL.
YOU KNOW LUNATIC HOBOS WHO BLURT
OUT CRAZY THINGS AND ZIGZAG IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CROWDED
INTERSECTION.
ADAM SCHIFF KIND OF SOUNDED LIKE
THAT TODAY.
>> THOSE NOTES REFLECT IS A
CLASSIC MAFIA LIKE SHAKEDOWN OF
A FOREIGN LEADER.
THIS IS HOW A MAFIA BOSS TALKS,
LIKE ANY MAFIA BOSS, THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T NEED TO SAY
THAT THE NICE COUNTRY YOU HAVE
AND BE -- IT WOULD BE A SHAME IF
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO IT.
>> Laura: THE MAN DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW THE GODFATHER.
HE DOESN'T KNOW THE MOVIE.
HE DOESN'T NOTICE SHAKEDOWN IS.
I REMEMBER ON THE DEMOCRATS TOLD
US THEY WERE GOING TO WORK ON
HEALTH CARE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY WERE GOING TO TAKE ON THE
DRUG COMPANIES.
DID NOT COME INTO ANY OF THAT.
TAKES US TO MY SEVENTH AND FINAL
POINT.
BIBLICAL.
DEMOCRATS ARE POSSESSED WITH
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE.
MAYBE THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
EXORCISM.
THEY ARE INFURIATED THAT MUELLER
LET THEM DOWN, THAT TRUMP HAS
BEATEN THEM PRETTY MUCH AT EVERY
TURN.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH PUNISHING
HIM AND ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR
HIM, ANYONE IS CLOSE TO HIM.
THINK ABOUT IT.
DOES LEADERSHIP GIVE IMPASSIONED
PRESS CONFERENCES ON THEIR PLANS
FOR REINING IN GOVERNMENT WASTE
AND FRAUD AND ABUSE?
IMPROVING THE ECONOMY?
NO, THEY SAVE ALL THEIR EMOTION
AND BOGUS INVESTIGATIONS AND
ANGRY DENUNCIATIONS OF ANYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
THE POLLS ARE CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT WHAT AMERICANS WANT.
THESE REPRESENTATIVES WERE NOT
SENT TO WASHINGTON TO FRUSTRATE
THE PEOPLE'S WILL.
THEY WERE SENT TO WASHINGTON TO
DO THE PEOPLE'S WILL.
AT THIS POINT, TRUMP IS DOING
THAT ALL OF HIS OWN.
SOON IT'S GOING TO TURN TO THE
PEOPLE.
THEY WILL HAVE THEIR SAY AND
THEY'RE GOING WASHINGTON KNOW
WHAT IT THINKS ABOUT THE JOB
THEY'VE DONE.
AND PROPERLY FRAMED, THE
ELECTION WILL BE A CHOICE
BETWEEN G DEMOCRATS, REVENGE AND
RESIST STYLE POLITICS, OR THE